per questo il nuovissimo video
bellissimo sud avrebbe siamo sul mio nel
mio nuovo studio che ancora appropriato
alla camera quindi vedete un po tagliato
dietro ma è normale ricevere ragazzi che
si adotterà la camera perché dobbiamo
ancora fare dei cambiamenti ma per
adesso proviamo a vedere se il computer
nuovo mi migliora le prestazioni di
gameplay cosa che secondo me ne faccio
schifo uguale però almeno computer è
bello non so se lo ricordate ragazzi
questo è praticamente un geometri nasce
in 3d poche parole non è riuscita con
una mazza perché direttamente faccio
schifo però vabbè chissenefrega questo
micro storia va bene a giocare mi
riporto più o meno ma discorso è che
devo riuscire a battere il livello
dell'altra volta
voglio far vedere che i miei 15 mila
euro di computer servono a giocare a
cose più importanti tipo quesito ad
esempio 9 per che cosa fosse un proprio
comitato igiene per questo è in graziate
che non sto facendo prato fiorito perché
sono per tutti e lo dico anche raga
niente male essere versati cerro perciò
il peso vecchio non ho capito bene se
effettivamente semovibili partirà search
di pavia 0 vis sarà la tira referti vado
a prendere il calendario volendo fosso è
proprio lui con tutte le monete parte
tentativi uno fantastico euro non sono
male mela dove ero morto l'ultima volta
era questa era arrivata a 39 per cento
ma facciamo direttamente questa ragazzi
perché cioè se facciamo le cose fatte
bene forte scherzavo era meglio lasciar
perdere
forse era meglio lasciar perdere proprio
proviamoci dai tentativo era arrivata al
39 per cento vedo
aspettate che il pavia nessuno computer
nuovo a porta valle voi non avete idea
di come il fallito computer
non ce l'avete guarda guarda guarda lo
speriamo non ci siano altri comandi che
mi hanno spiegato solo questi quindi va
bene un ragazzino promesse gioco qua
posso dire la verità è molto
sottovalutato perché molto figo nel
senso non so perché non abbiano non so
perché non ti esploso come geometri
lascia molto bello sarò al 39 per cento
almeno perché quel casino
[Musica]
forte ha trovato fatto 36 36 o ragazzi e
non ci gioco saranno cinque anni che non
45 anni quando è l'ultimo di andata a
vedere subito qual è l'ultimo video che
ho fatto questa roba
sono cinque anni che non gioco sono
arrivati quasi al punteggio dell'altra
volta non è male è una mera nel male
laga posso fare di meglio possa arrivare
nella 50 almeno 50 ma perché questo
pensa una sfida contro me stesso
ripartiamo lavoravano rimasti credo che
la il set
più o meno alla ragazzi proverò
concentrarmi adesso fa chiede la parte
difficile non parlo perché tramis
concentro da solo sto zitto vediamo cosa
succede
e poi magari faccio pagare uguale pro ci
provo
[Musica]
h vacca porta porca vacca dovevo andare
a destra o affanculo dovevano schiantato
l'altra volta stavolta hanno piantato lì
perché non ho capito la tecnologia
diventa sinistra ma che è ma che è sta
roba
l'inter arriva ragazzi scommesse
un'altra che poi con il baby tagli ma
sono tutti sanno arrivare di grazia con
gila la stessa dove magari propria
fucina di progetti che poi c'è pure il
muro quindi pure difficile mannaia ci
provo ci prova raga ma [ __ ]
ragazzi difficilissimo e direi è
veramente difficile bbj è impossibile
gira a destra sinistra non so perché no
giuro ma non so perché ma è
difficilissimo girare la testa a
sinistra per ostico anche impegnata a
qualche zitto perché sono stato zitto
primi concentrazione massima la vi
assicuro che con la concentrazione
massima è un gattino uguale
cosa c'è là non c'era netto stacco di
quel fatto e non riesco comunque come è
veramente difficile ci troviamo far
cacciamatta il casinò ricordare computer
nuova forza mannaggia cacchio fa dalla
stessa forma
gli studenti o quale sto domandando e
coloro i quali rischio vero come la
sfruttiamo st 3090 è ecco visto
[Musica]
o o
età supremo per girarmi la porco del
demonio
mi sembra perché poi tutti per sempre
sinistra e destra ma quello all'indietro
progresso pazzi c'è un mandato d'arresto
perché ha fatto stato sì speriamo di sì
c'è proprio scritto uguale non abbiamo
arrestato e non si può è illegale lo
studio si può che lega
[Musica]
no murray bile forse devo fare così tipo
duro faccio questa cosa perché è
difficilissimo schiacciare a sinistra
con il tagliando la testa perché tutto
al contrario è difficilissimo proposta
tattica adesso farà ridere che mi metto
al contrario ma provo veramente perché
secondo me è così riesco ok
[Musica]
ma le gambe e come fare squat terribile
per la funzionaria lo proporrei qui ecco
cosa no dai
però vedi che a volte i q 2 mila solo a
volte però funziona
fatemi vedere come giocavo una volta sta
roba per curiosità problema guadagnato
che fra cinque anni fa ragazzi febbraio
del 2016 invece alla 2020 sento mamma
melia 95 non va bene non fate con la fia
europa sembravo quali generica questa
era da del 2021 vediamo poi nel 2026 a
questo punto tech che si fa così vi
abbraccio ragazzi grazie per aver
seguito il video del momento mi piace
anche lei social milan transizione se ne
sono visti discrete vi io sto cercando
telefonando ma mi sa che non ce l'ho
nello studio che dovrete anche fisico
bella ragazza
[Musica]